you know I think we all can agree that
right now more than ever we can use a
laugh and all you have to do is go back
and enjoy the work of Carl Reiner the
Hollywood legend passed away yesterday
at the age of 98 comedy really was
Carl's life and he never stopped making
us smile
[Music]
well that I made people laugh yeah
that's the nicest thing really
influenced my decision what is it what
is the money you got the part there the
back shut up no Carl may have been best
known for creating writing and starring
in the Dick Van Dyke Show and we
witnessed the special bond between the
two firsthand today dick posted this pic
saying 100% pure mensch we love you so
much so are you sure you're ready to do
this today Carl's Ocean's eleven co-star
George Clooney tweeted Carl Reiner made
every room he walked into funnier
smarter kinder what an incredible gift
he gave us all rest in peace my friend
this is et Mel Kohi team and this is one
of my favorite shows throughout his
seventy year career Carl had an
incredible circle of stars and comedic
legends by his side
this weekend we saw this post Carl
having dinner with close friend Mel
Brooks who just turned in 94 well Mel
Brooks is the oldest you moving you know
he's 2,000 and the funniest single human
being that ever was existed in our life
we made three wonderful adults adults
they were kids originally Carl was
extremely devoted to his family in one
of his final tweets the dad and grandpa
six honored his kids in late wife
Estelle saying nothing pleases me more
than knowing I have lived the best life
possible by having them today his eldest
son actor Rob Reiner posted last night
my dad passed away as I write this my
heart is hurting
he was my guiding light when I was eight
years old III went to my parents and I
said I I want to change my name
my dad was all worried so what do you
want to change your name - I said Carl
because because that's what that's who I
looked up to you turning 97 in March if
I lived that long but I will because I
have things to do
you can't die if you have things to do
recently Carl was busy writing several
books and in 2017 he became the oldest
Emmy nominee ever for his HBO
documentary if you're not in the open
eat breakfast it means I'm still alive
that's a very important thing to be but
of all Carl's accomplishments
there was one closest to his heart night
show I've done a lot of things in my
life and they said what are you most
proud most proudest beside my kids in it
I said the Dick Van Dyke Show I said it
that's good I can put that on my
tombstone the first 30 or 40 episodes I
wrote by myself I was my own producer
and story editor and it really is part
of my life part of me Carl gave Mary
Tyler Moore her big break she walked
through the door and I saw those legs
that hair those eyes and I said I gave
her a page from the script let's come
with me young lady
later in life Carl took on more acting
roles he kind of stole the spotlight
from George Matt and Brad we're just
supposed to walk out of there with a
hundred and fifty million dollars in
cash on us without getting stopped yeah
okay the biggest surprise is that they
everybody knows they're good actors
there's no question about everybody
knows they're handsome that's very
apparent but what they don't know is
that the most decent human beings I've
ever met I'm just visiting from floor
not staying very long but would you yes
and maybe tomorrow yes Carl also shared
the screen with fellow legend Betty
White
their friendship began in the 50s I've
loved this girl since I first saw her on
the Betty White show how many years ago
Oh
75 and I was under her husband's command
and the South in the Pacific captain
Allen Ludden was my captain and when he
married this lovely I said what a match
and I consider her my captain in law one
of Carl's final roles was the voice of
the rhinoceros in Toy Story 4 it's the
last thing we ever got to play that
today Tom Hanks posted goodbye Carl
thank you for my joy filled youth we all
go in the business to be liked to
pleasure
Oh
[Music]